la situación humanitaria Es crítica en
Ucrania la oficina de monitoreo de
derechos humanos de Naciones Unidas para
el país europeo desveló en un informe
parte de los efectos en la población por
la invasión rusa los civiles asesinados
se cuentan por miles
la guerra ha producido un costo humano
horrendo hasta esta semana hemos
documentado más de 8.000 civiles que han
muerto y casi 14.000 que han resultado
heridos
más del 90% fueron causados por misiles
armas o Minas explosivas y restos
explosivos de guerra
desde el 24 de febrero del año pasado la
organización ha documentado 621 casos de
desapariciones forzadas y detenciones
arbitrarias de civiles por parte de las
fuerzas armadas rusas y también reportó
133 casos de violencia sexual
relacionados con el conflicto otras de
las modalidades que preocupan a la ONU
son los traslados irregulares que
incluyen niños no acompañados desde
diversas ucranianas mientras estaban
bajo control ruso
También estamos profundamente
preocupados por la ejecución sumaria de
15 prisioneros de guerra ucranianos Poco
después de ser capturados por las
fuerzas armadas rusas los contratistas
militares y de seguridad del grupo
Wagner perpetraron 11 de estas
ejecuciones
pero aseguro que Ucrania tampoco ha
estado exenta de esas prácticas y ha
documentado la ejecución sumaria de 25
prisioneros de guerra rusos
la ONU también de lato casos de tortura
por parte de las fuerzas rusas más del
84% de los soldados detenidos
entrevistados por la misión sufrió tales
malos tratos